et nous sommes avec françois géré
historien spécialiste en géostratégie
président fondateur de l'institut
français d'analysé stratégique bonjour
bonjour merci d'être avec nous peut-être
un commentaire sur la libération de sept
israélo américaine de 26 ans alors que
benyamin nétanyahou se trouve justement
à mouscou ce que c'est un geste
justement qu'on peut interpréter un
geste de bienvenue de l'apparat du
président russe dans cette la décision
avait été prise avant pendant
déplacement du président poutine en
israël il y avait eu des discussions sur
le sujet et le président poutine à frère
avait fait savoir qu'il regarderait ce
cas avec bienveillance et donc
effectivement la suite logique
c'est cette décision d'aujourd'hui à
l'occasion du déplacement de monsieur
netanyahou alors benyamin nétanyahou qui
vient défendre le plan de paix
israélo-palestinien proposait donc
dévoilé par donald trump
d'abord on sait que l'onu par exemple
ainsi sur la nécessité d'une solution
qui respecte le droit international dans
le cadre ce cas précis le cas
israélo-palestinien respecter le droit
international ça veut dire quoi
concrètement ça veut dire en particulier
prendre en compte le problème des
colonies des colonies et là on est
évidemment tout à fait en dehors de ce
qu'on appelle le droit international
puisque les territoires palestiniens
sont reconnus comme étant intègres et
donc relevant de l'autorité
palestinienne alors que là le plan de
donald trump est en train d'en terminer
dans les fêtes la colonisation et de
donner effectivement à israël d un feu
vert pour maintenir des établissements
qui n'ont en fait aucune légalité
et puis il ya la question de jérusalem
aussi puisque ce plan prône justement
chef dans le même temps ils calculent
indivisible d'israël
il est bien évident que la question de
jérusalem c'est tard excellence le
deux types de conditions inacceptables
pour les palestiniens à qui on propose
d'avoir un état avec une capitale qui
serait en dehors de jérusalem
même si elle était à proximité donc en
fait il n'y a rien à négocier
alors la russie m comment va-t-elle se
positionner puisque la firme qu'elle va
pas se prononcer sans l'avis des
israéliens d'une part et la vie des
palestiniens
ça ça fait partie de la démarche du
président poutine qui consiste à se
poser autant que possible en médiateur
donc il a des relations extrêmement
eux soutenu avec benyamin netanyahou il
y as avec les israéliens des points
d'accord sur un certain nombre de
domaines et aussi des points de
désaccord notamment la syrie l'iran etc
et
le président poutine souhaite sur la
question israélo-palestinienne continuer
à discuter avec les deux camps
et si possible arrivée à rapprocher les
deux parties mais il est bien évident
qu'il ne va pas promouvoir le plan de
paix de donald trump
donc il a sa propre approche et il peut
faire comprendre à benyamin nétanyahou
qu' il y à un certain nombre de choses
qui sont acceptables et d'autres qui ne
le sont pas et du côté de benyamin
nétanyahou
quels sont les arguments que lui peut
avancer peut-être des arguments
économiques
il ya des arguments économiques bien
évidemment mais le fond du problème
reste politique
je ne crois pas que dans l'état actuel
des choses on puisse considérer que les
palestiniens puissent satisfaire d'un
certain nombre d'avantagés économiques
alors que de la question politique est
complètement avait évacué alors que les
territoires encore une fois sont menacés
d'occupation permanente par la
colonisation
toutes choses qui sont des causes de
rupture de discussions avec israël alors
on voit ici un des images en direct
justement de l'entretien qui a débuté
entre vladimir poutine et le premier
ministre israélien benyamin nétanyahou
donc à mouscou discussion donc à propos
justement de ce plan de paix pour le
proche orient qui a été proposé par
donald trump est une question que l'on a
d'une femme on a du mal à comprendre
finalement la position de la communauté
internationale qui dans son ensemble
accueille avec beaucoup de
circonspection justement se plante pll
ne tranche pas dans le même temps
comment vous l'expliquez qu'on appelle
la communauté internationale est quand
même extrêmement divisé sur la question
israélo palestinienne
il ya évidemment les états unis d'un
côté avec un certain nombre de pays qui
les suivent
puis il y a parmi les membres de
sécurité du parmi les membres permanents
du conseil de sécurité des nations unies
un certain nombre de pays qui estiment
que le droit international comme on l'a
dit tout à l'heure ne permet pas
d'accepter un certain nombre de choses
il ya la question de jérusalem avec
là le problème de la capitale et à la
question comme on disait décolonisation
et pour un certain nombre de pays
cette situation defacto n'est pas
acceptable et donc on ne peut pas
reconnaître par exemple jérusalem comme
capitale de l'état d'israël
il ya ce plan de paix aujourd'hui on a
eu d'autres auparavant
qu'est ce qu'il ya qu'est-ce qui a
toujours bloqués assez rapidement ce qui
a bloqué rapidement c'est tout
simplement que les objectifs ne sont pas
les mêmes il ya un blocage entre les
israéliens et les palestiniens
mais il faut rappeler qu'il ya aussi un
blocage parmi les palestiniens
les objectifs des blocages entre le
fatah et le hamas
entre le fatah et le hamas
la politique suivie par monsieur abbas
n'est pas reconnu par une partie des
palestiniens en particulier à gaza mais
aussi dans certains secteurs des
territoires occupés donc dans ces
conditions là il n'y a pas deux
interlocuteurs face à face il y a un
interlocuteur israélien et il ya eu
plusieurs vues du problème par les
palestiniens refusent toujours de
reconnaître et israël aussi bien sûr et
encore une fois c'est la dernière carte
dont dispose de palestiniens la
reconnaissance d'israël
il ne la lâcheront pas comme ça merci
beaucoup françois à gérer je rappelle
que vous êtes historien spécialiste en
géostratégie président fondateur de
l'institut français d'analysé
stratégique merci à vous